[Applause]
your first Matt gout yes describe the
feeling you're walking up the famous
smack out of stairs yes it feels amazing
it feels just like the stairs that I
used to walk up when I was at high
school except I'm wearing a pretty dress
and know that now I wondered where's the
white dress we're Alexander McQueen yes
it's in the copy because Alexander
didn't offer to dress me but you know
who did Brandon Maxwell represent
looking good football with me any woman
could wear it it hello hot and sex yeah
I do feel hot I feel pretty moist
now tell me any secrets to the dress
well no longer take pants suit jacket
situation Rihanna showed up as a sexy Co
Sarah Jessica Parker has an entire altar
on her hand are you ready to get down on
the dance floor yeah I play I'm caring
the party no happiness no no I don't
need nothing messing with my crown
chakra okay my crown chakra hoping one
chakra open throat chakra open and the
root chakra is ready yeah wait a minute
hello that was rich me in here at this
[Music]